j'étais à 42 semaines de grossesse
c'était dans la nuit
faisait froid dehors de la mare de sang
neuf au match 7 à l'automne il faisait
beau un plaisir mon ex mari et est posé
deux parties la journée la journée de la
fin puis jallet a retenu pour qu'ils
restent avec moi bien
les contres actionnaire commun c'est le
d'énerver aussi parce qu'on n'avait pas
d'auto puis maglio succès ses quinze
kilos mais l'âge de briquettes je savais
possible de la voir c'était une fille ou
un garçon maria s'est présenté en
octobre 2007 à l'hôpital enceinte de son
septième enfant c'était mon deuxième le
travail il avait fait très bien un
travail qui se passait relativement
normalement
éventuellement ça a gagné le médecin et
argent tripes nous sommes en toupie au
livre ben hur
l'obstétricienne jeu nicolas qui était
ce rappel est venu sur les lieux parce
qu'on lui a demandé une consultation
et a commencé à parler de césariennes et
du fait même en pendant la césarienne on
pourrait vous faire une ligature des
trompes
elle a dit non c'est juste signé comme
quoi que je te d'accord d'avoir une
césarienne
je signale un lot de papier pour un des
gâteaux avant de partir
je l'entends je arriver
c'est mélanie très chanceuse j'arrête la
place cet après midi jeux pourquoi mais
pour te faire une ligature des trompes
les minutes passent à cela c'est une
question de
ma ville
moi j'ai pas le temps de réfléchir parce
que j'avais déjà mes contractions aussi
ses craintes étaient mal de ses pas le
temps de réfléchir
pour elle elle a subi une césarienne
puis ça s'arrête là elle ne se doutait
aucunement qu'on lui avait clips et les
trompes
sont en train d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore
il y en a d'autres
on va le découvrir
moment et ariane metellus je suis
accompagnantes périnatale mère de cinq
enfants et militante en venir à
accompagner des femmes racisées c'est à
partir de mon expérience de mes
expériences de grossesse et
d'accouchement
witch time to ariane metellus farwind
edf joy et chaque one oui bon tout
document unique world is in 2010 cofield
ariane hausse de ses objectifs
jusqu'à la berline le canada wide stasi
en nature nous réserve je sais que dans
les communautés noires particulièrement
il se passe des choses je sais que les
femmes vivent des choses ça va de
du regard ça va d'aider
les commentaires or vous on sait berne
afrique écoutez madame on n'est pas dans
la jungle a ici
je me sens intéressé en fait aux
violences obstétricales en général avant
de m'intéresser
particulièrement aux stérilisations non
consenti which i discovered à dos d'âne
en expected bière et de stirling points
black
list
airlines ou c est
le cas de maria bhl mariam a été référée
par une professionnelle la santé qui a
travaillé avec elle auprès d'elle on
sait mariage de son 7e sa septième
grossesse
c'est une femme noire
d'un certain âge ce qui est déplorable
c'est que
marianne s'attendait pas à voir une
césarienne donc là non seulement on lui
annonce que bolat va devoir avoir une
césarienne au plus bas et de oui en même
temps on peut profiter pour faire une
ligature tubert ouimette luis mejía et
n'a
rencontré et merci d'être là
j'ai surtout chez qui
elle a dit on va fait non un alligator
détrompent
j'ai dit mais tu vas fait une césarienne
est négatif de 36 croit
elle a dit qu'il se passe c'est quoi une
algue hâtive des tombes jésus mais non
madame ne vise pas la du oui les choses
tu fais les bébés les césariennes pas de
problème
mais pour faire les allégations des tons
passager doit pas les c'est mon médecin
famille qui doit expliquer moi ça on
peut mettre ça sur un problème de langue
un manque de communication
un malentendu
mais je pense que ça va un petit peu
plus loin que ça je pense qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de paternalisme et
d'infantilisation
on sait ce qui est bon pour toi donc
beaucoup de douleur oui
ça va faire trois ans là bientôt qui
elle en parle encore avec souffrance
elle en parle elle l ensemble l ampleur
des piles et angers a beaucoup de
tristesse ge a beaucoup de décoller mais
c'est j je veux demander à l pourquoi
elle a person décision
pour moi même
s comme tu sais
oui j'en ai entendu des histoires pour
moi le cadre de mariée n'était qu'une
confirmation on l'entend dans les
communautés autochtones ici au canada au
canada
ce qui n est solide et on se dit que
connection between the story of black
[Musique]
je m'appelle aller salon bord je suis
l'avocat qui mènent leur collectif pour
les femmes autochtones qui ont été
stérilisés sans leur consentement au
manitoba et en saskatchewan
je suis maman à deux petites filles
mariées avec un homme crie je suis
d'héritage league man et acadiennes
j'aurai reçu un appel d'une femme qui
m'aurait dit ceci c'est même ça m'est
arrivé j'étais donné naissance à mon
bébé et puis j'en suis sorti stérilisés
je me suis dit bon ça se peut pas
[Musique]
when she just cette date à
laquelle
les spécialistes
et fois que l'on vous dire pour fêter
les commentaires sur les articles
étaient vraiment perturbant y croyez pas
ça se pourrait avoir une raison elle se
trompe a mal compris
alors c'était un peu le discours qu'on
attendait ou ou bon à plusieurs d'autres
propos racistes et stéréotypique qui
essentiellement qui suggérerait que les
femmes de mérite
chez
les femmes on commence à en parler et
puis après ça il y avait une femme une
autre femme une autre femme une autre
femme moyens prends comme un conte bien
avant qu'on commence à changer les
affaires c'est pas le droit qui manque
de droits sur le consentement est très
très clair alors il ya madame qui est au
travail sa capacité est bon on doit
comprendre impacté
par l'état dans laquelle elle se trouve
un an tout leur et c'est alors la
coercition il n'en faut pas beaucoup 1
dans le set et aux leurs on peut dire
bon je pense que vous devriez faire ça
ok ce que vous dites je vais le faire
mais ça c'est le problème c'est que cela
ce n'est pas le consentement éclairé
elle bat le havre de
paix
car c'est un environnement qui est
approprié pour considérer les formations
qu'on reçoit de son médecin alors les
risques les options les conséquences les
bénéfices etc alors nous on dit une
femme qui est en plein travail est en
train d'avoir un bébé ne peut pas
consentir à
une stérilisation permanent ou semi
permanent il n'ya rien d'urgent il y a
rien de thérapeutique il n'y a rien de
médicalement nécessaires
[Musique]
mimos lac le titre get the best practice
qui sont ces femmes les minorités
visibles
les minorités visibles je dire c'est une
question de la couleur de peau et de la
race que le médecin votre député et je
me suis dit ça peut m'arriver à moi
aussi facilement ça peut arriver à mes
filles ça arrive à ma belle soeur ça
peut arriver mais est ce l'objectif de
rgo collectif traditionnellement c'est
la modification du comportement alors
c'est ce qu'on cherche en premier
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui à la nationale 2
présent nous allons voir comment le
gouvernement fédéral pratique le
génocide des inuit
[Musique]
il part au monde connaît ton un peuple
dont le tiers des femmes en âge de
procréer soit systématiquement
stérilisés pour comprendre il faut dire
d'abord que l'homme qu'on vient
d'entendre et le père robert de chaque
écurie à igloolik dans les territoires
du nord-ouest et que les femmes dont il
parle sont les inuit communément appelée
esquimaude dans le sud
il y avait un prêtre il travaillait dans
plusieurs de ces communautés inuites il
a dénoncé ce qu'il voyait comme des
stérilisations forcées il avait dit je
pense des consentements extorqué ccimo
mon nom et ça me chagrine houssen je
suis enfant ni en fait de parents
immigrants moi-même du coup je suis
comme je suis pédiatre urgentiste
crusade
d'investigation en colonie médicaux fils
bongo
phare de richard
ville voyez ça dans un contexte où il
disait que le gouvernement fédéral ne
voulait pas payer pour ces personnes-là
les enfants qui allait naître mais pour
lui c'est toujours une question à ces
politiques qui voulaient dénoncer
à votre avis quelle est la raison qui
pousse le gouvernement fédéral à vouloir
réduire le nombre d enfants par famille
skis monde
[Musique]
sait aussi ancrée dans un contexte plus
large de colonialisme canadien qui
existaient qui avait pur pour but de
éliminé en fait les autochtones des
collectivités autochtones
accaparé leurs terres et leurs
ressources le projet ça est toujours été
motivé cette passe
mais quelle raison est ce qu'on donne
aux femmes pour leur proposer la
stérilisation
[Musique]
c'est pas faux vrai
c'est que je puis affirmer avec
certitude c'est que dans 99 des cas ce
n'est pas la femme et la première
[Musique]
et une thèse à bâle médecin il me fait
départ quand même l'un des deux enfants
déjà proche l'un de ses seins
indifférence le troisième ce dangereux
pour toi folle enfants vont mourir ou
toi toi des complications c'est
dangereux vous pouvez pas voir d'autres
bd
vous allez mourir si vous avez un bébé
là vous avez déjà des enfants qui sont à
la guerre de l'état s'est pas déjà assez
on sait bien que vous allez finir dans
le dans l'alcool dans la consommation
pis tout six minutes à red solo pickton
et puis tu vois les pertes des enfants
ben là c'est assez
puis ce monde là il faut nommer des
enfants
bah si elles veulent pas arrêter de
faire des enfants
ben nous on va s'en occuper
puis ça vienne chercher aussi parce que
moi aussi j'ai beaucoup d'enfants
tu es là j'en suis à cinq et je les
entends ces commentaires il ya vraiment
commune on dirait presque une intention
de persuader avec la honte
[Musique]
ce qui a été dit dans la vidéo just en
fait pour moi c'était très clair que
c'est juste quelque chose que beaucoup
de personnes dans le milieu de la santé
pense qu'ils vont peut-être pas le dire
explicitement mais ça se reflète dans
leurs gestes puis dans leurs
interventions
[Musique]
going back in time
machine fortes chaleurs et nos registres
de contrôle et de bmx des génériques
supériorité
[Musique]
manager knicks practice in canada huit
unités entre 1920 jusqu'en 1970 il y
avait deux lois qui ont été adoptées en
colombie-britannique et en alberta
des lois sur la stérilisation et puis
souvent qu'on parle de ces circulations
parle des personnes en guinée
handicapé mental on voyait des centaines
et des centaines de ces personnes là qui
est testé risée mais ce qui est clair
c'est que les femmes et les filles à doc
tonnes était impacté de façon
disproportionnée puis dans les autres
provinces il y avait quand même des
mouvements semblables inspiré par
logis du jeunisme
in nineteenth aventi new democratic idée
de luis christine des ministres en
charge de time jean chrétien
[Musique]
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait une telle
occasion
de first days in paris
dans lequel doit
donc les pratiques de stérilisation
forcée et corrective continuer dans
certains hôpitaux indiens
vingtaine
et n'intervenir
[Musique]
response
or à ce jour personne du ministère
fédéral de la santé ou du ministère des
affaires indiennes et du nord n'a daigné
répondre ou démentir les accusations qui
découle forcément de cet état de fait à
savoir que le gouvernement fédéral est
en train de pratiquer les génocides une
population autochtone du grand nord
c'est révoltant que il ya eu des gens
qui dénoncent cette réalité depuis
maintenant des décennies
et que on est encore là à plusieurs
égards ces pratiques ont continué d'une
façon ou d'une autre en fait c'était
juste
peut-être un peu plus se cacher la plus
subtile disons ça a continué
et
et spencer doman
signalisation en
france
c'est devenu un peu inquiète je sais pas
si je peux le dire comme ça mais pour
moi c'est
si le summum des violences là qu'une
femme peut subir
de lui ôter ce droit de se reproduire
d'enfanter sans qu'elle ne l'ait demandé
même que je te fais 19 timoun ça c'est à
moi c'est moi qui décide si tu pu
enlever mon pompe c'est mon cas
c'est mon décision c'est là qu'elle a
commencé à entamer des procédures pour
aller au bout de l'histoire plus pour
comprendre ce qui lui était arrivé et
tout
comme
j'en ai entendu des choses des
hystérectomie sans consentement
quelqu'un qui se réveille après une
opération tout autre pour quelque chose
d'autre puis qui
a qui ont dit oui finalement on a dû
vous enlevez votre utérus on saute aux
conclusions un scénario mais elle prend
en considération le monde ariane au
sommet twin prêcheurs de troubles la
galerie actuelle
il ya une infirmière qui arrivent et qui
a commencé à poser des questions comme
pour valider des choses donc je
répondais oui non oui puis à un moment
donné la demande et oui est ce qu'on
fait bien une ligature des trompes
après la césarienne puis honnêtement
j'ai pas prêté attention à la question
parce que c'était avant d'entrer au bloc
opératoire et donc elle a dit ça et puis
moi je suis là oui oui puis
mon conjoint du temps à demander à oui
tu veux faire ça je dis me faire quoi
le samedi la pose d'un jean slim
je vais je vais t'en pire
personne avec mona dans ma chambre qui
est femme n'était pas la leur
j'avais pas j'avais peur que prenne mon
bébé j'étais un peu on est en stress en
bauxite est à mon avis faire l'opération
hélas je suis revenu à moi même je dis
mais non mais pourquoi
vous voulez avoir d'autres enfants chez
eux oui je pars c'est mon autre enfant
qui est à la maison puisque we drame ans
et c'est quoi
car qu'elle est revenue
jean
je voulais pas
qu'ils voulaient pas
qu'il ait pas fait
[Musique]
et non
moi j'étais le gars a tiré à l'âge de 18
ans une grande opération jeu ça reste
quoi
me ligaturer là je savais poster quoi
c'était dans ma communauté j'en connais
une coupe les femmes qui ont subi
des stérilisations
sens large pansement
puis m'ont fait pas parce qu'ils m'ont
dit si tu fais pour tous avoir des
enfants sur un podium où
est
ma copine me
[Musique]
le
hockey qui m'attache les trous
j'étais un homme violent n'est vraiment
pas
[Musique]
mon mari
l'avait non pas vraiment mais j'avais
copwatch
rgt pas la passion de classiques parce
que j'étais un
migrantes sans assurance maladie est-ce
que c'était bienveillance je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas parce que ce sont pas le
genre de décisions qu'on prend la place
de quelqu'un et ce serait pas de la
bienveillance pour moi c'est presque un
crime et quelques années plus tard je
voulais avoir un autre enfant tu sais
que je suis qu'est ce que je pourrais
plus jamais avoir d'enfant
parce qu'ils n'ont coupé les drames a
même tenté de brûler
quand je lis et de vue il dit jah fin du
gel mauvaises nouvelles een jockey il
est ensuite rentré tout d'une première
pour toi et je dit on pas coupé ils
n'ont pas grippée il ya tout brûler j'ai
fait un des traits sans billet je me
sentais pas bien
si comme je dis je me sentais fini
[Musique]
je pourrais plus jamais été avec un an
tu veux des enfants
je suis après quelques mois là que
j'étais je pouvais trois membres ainsi
que tout un chacun pour war
feghouli
la joie d'avoir des enfants
c'est comme si encore plus je me sentais
écrasé
puis j'ai commencé à douter de moi après
j'ai commencé à douter de mes capacités
parentales je me suis longtemps parce
ça ne m'est pas
comme la rage à nos hôtes et des
voyageurs
[Musique]
comme une de mes amis m'appellent
souvent tout les jours puis à placer 18
eu des choses aux passionnés rabière
j'ai la rage
for more
years the women who came
quand tu as
[Musique]
entre night in his own words
alors
32 33
semaines enceinte j'ai monté l'avion
avec la permission de mon médecin et je
me suis déplacé à genève pour présenter
à ce comité
l'expérience le vécu
de nos clientes j'avais les mains
pleines a tout simplement expliqué à
quel point la stérilisation sans
consentement force et c'est un
traitement qui est cruel au plein milieu
du briefing bien sûr le rapporteur d'une
annoncé cesser la torture on a déjà
décidé ça fait longtemps
c'était quand même pas honte absolue
mais aucun c'était sérieux c'était des
nous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
prévenir la pratique de la stérilisation
forcée ce qui constitue la torture en
droit international de nous ce que vous
avez fait pour punir ceux qui sont
responsables examiner votre code pénal
de nook est ce que vous allez faire pour
réparer
non monsieur bitter une femme jenny va
lui ce phénomène
de ghettoïsation in saskatoon revenir à
sa chance
depuis le savoir que
ça c'est le produit qui composent la
colline est en
vigueur
ries solomon des nano conduite majeur
have been taken in canada on vous assure
qu'il ya des mesures qui ont été prises
lesquelles allaient les qu'elle allait
expliquer les femmes veut savoir c'est
quoi les mesures
jusqu'à date ce qu'on voit c'est des
réunions et ce qui sauf qu'en ce moment
là les femmes c'est les familles de
leurs enfants
c'est une souffrance
[Musique]
nicolas fontaine
de jeunesse physique chimie comme
président un tel acte
[Musique]
il faut vraiment avoir une tolérance
zéro à travers le système de santé pour
dire non à ces pratiques c'est politique
coloniale qui continue à ce jour où un
acte
inadmissible
[Musique]
moi j'essaie d'être très claires par le
fait que moi j'ai participé dans cette
pratique est ignoble qui existait depuis
des décennies donc je ne prétends pas
être quelqu'un qui est pur ou qui
avaient qui ne faisaient pas partie de
ça je faisais partie mais ça veut ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas un
moment donné rompre essayer de
confronter
ces pratiques injustes
et
le physicien
colonisation
il ya un esprit de corps et à l'impunité
qui existent aussi je pense pas que les
gens
toutes ces stérilisation auront pu ce
faire toutes ces années là s'il n'y
avait pas un sentiment d'impunité
on ne peut pas quand même pratique et la
ligature des trompes de force sur une
femme il faut quand même leur
autorisation et dans certains cas une
autorisation écrite
[Musique]
in january toit ni toi ni les galeristes
que c'est une omission
c'est une erreur grave
c'est une faute grave
je suis d'avis qu'il est possible de
conclure que l'état dans lequel vous
étiez dans ces minutes qui ont précédé
votre césarienne et pu altérer votre
compréhension de la chirurgie
stérilisant proposée dans la note
réponse là la qualité du consentement a
pas été respecté
c'est quoi la conséquence
de
l'adopter soutient s'être dit qu'il
était de son devoir de vous informer de
l'option de la ligature tubert
mais ce qu'on a donné à cette femme là
la possibilité d'aller chercher par
exemple deuxième avis puisque c'était
pas une situation urgente
donc merci docteur
de prendre ce devoir là coeur donnez-moi
toutes les informations puis je vais
aller faire mes recherches je vais
prendre ma décision j'ai réfléchir
de colonisation nous avons investigué
vous savez que je fais pas commenté
publiquement le corps particulier comme
président je peux pas perso
je suis très mal à l'aise avec ça très
préoccupé par le fait qu'il puisse y
avoir au québec des stérilisations non
consenti je vous dis qu'il ya un rappel
qui va être fait pour que de telles
décisions certains dans les meilleures
circonstances possibles ou permettre à
la patiente de prendre la meilleure
décision pour elle et comme
professionnel il faut laisser
le temps
[Musique]
pour
moi ça m'a paru directives explicites
mais plutôt par une prise de conscience
une sensibilisation la possibilité de
donner des concerts j'en avais moi aussi
[Musique]
un
one pas
une excuse sans changement comportement
est quand même assez vide
c'est mieux que rien mais à mon avis nos
clientes et les femmes autochtones qui
sont en train de naissance se mérite
beaucoup plus qu'un c'est mieux que rien
dans le cas de mme arrière est pour a
part avoir s'est trompé pour
mais un peu de dignité d'êtres messiah
personnes qui en parle dans les
conclusions
la personne qui parle d'elle de son
sentiment elle c'est comme si
indicatrices qui est là qui veut qcm
bleus sur
même que ça aguerris s'arrête ou non
c'est comme ça jamais guéri pour la vie
est arrivé ça ça me touche beaucoup de
basques et je fais partie de ses gains
je me dis pourquoi pas monter fournit
des êtres humains c'est renier tout
pareil c'est juste une femme autochtone
je suis fier de l'être aussi
geipan de marrast
ce contact des femmes qui parlent qu'ils
sont capables de parler même si après
des années je me suis sentie pas une
bonne main bachy celui-là puis je vois
avec mes enfants que je suis une bonne
heure
[Musique]